BASE HAS BEEN RADICALIZED AND
THEY'RE WITH PEOPLE LIKE
MASTRIANO AND TRUMP.
>> JOE, LET ME GET YOUR REACTION
TO WHAT HAPPENED AT C PAC THIS
WEEK, NOT HERE IN WASHINGTON BUT
IN HUNGARY.
YES, IN HUNGARY.
WHERE THEY HEARD FROM
ANTI-IMMIGRANT LEADER VICTOR
ORBON.
IT WAS ENTITLED WESTERN UNDER
ATTACK.
AND DURING HIS SPEECH HE SAID
WHAT AMERICA NEEDS MORE OF IS
TUCKER CARLSON.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> Translator: OF COURSE THE
GRAND OLD PARTY HAS ASSOCIATES
IN THE MEDIA.
ASSOCIATED MEDIA.
BUT THEY DO NOT COMPETE FOR THE
DOMINANCE OF THE LIBERAL PRESS.
ONLY MY FRIEND TUCKER CARLSON
PLACES HIMSELF ON THE LINE WITH
THE WAIVERING.
HIS NEW PROGRAM IS THE MOST
WATCHED.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
IT MEANS THAT PROGRAMS LIKE HIS
SHOULD RUN DAY AND NIGHT, AS YOU
SAY, 24/7.
>> SO HE IS PLUGGING TUCKER
CARLSON AT THIS DICTATOR PALOOZA
IN HUNGARY.
>> OUTSIDE OF DONALD TRUMP,
NOBODY CHANNELS THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY VOTER BETTER THAN TUCKER
CARLSON RIGHT NOW.
AGAIN, THIS IS SAD BECAUSE IT IS
A PARTY THAT HAS GIVEN UP ON
DEMOCRACY.
THEY NO LONGER BELIEVE IN THIS
IT AND THEY WANT AN
AUTHORITARIAN.
THEY WANT A PUTIN, THEY WANT AN
ORBAN, THEY WANT A TRUMP OR
DeSANTIS HERE WHO ACTS LIKE AN
AUTHORITARIAN.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHERE TODAY'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS, AND IT
SHOULD SCARE THE HELL OUT OF
EVERY AMERICAN.
>> THIS IS WEIRD, ISN'T IT?
TO HAVE C PAC HOLDING A
CONFERENCE IN HUNGARY WHERE
THERE'S AN AUTHORITARIAN LEADER
TALKING ABOUT TUCKER -- I MEAN,
THE -- WHAT WORLD ARE WE IN?
THIS IS THE TWILIGHT ZONE.
>> I THINK -- LET'S BE HONEST,
JIM.
SOME OF THE CONVENTIONS IN
RECENT YEARS HAVE BECOME FREAK
SHOWS, CLOWN SHOWS.
THE FACT THEY'RE GOING TO
HUNGARY TO CELEBRATE THIS
LEADER, IF YOU WANT TO CALL HIM
THAT, IS REALLY QUITE SHAMEFUL.
ONE OF THE GREAT CHALLENGES FROM
MY VIEW IS THAT WE HAVE LOST
THIS INTERNATIONAL FLARE THAT WE
HAVE HAD FOR YEARS.
WE WERE THE PARTY THAT STOOD UP
TO AUTOCRATS AND WE BELIEVED
STRONGLY IN THE TRANSATLANTIC
RELATIONSHIP AND NATO.
AND WE BELIEVED IN THINGS
ABOUT -- AT LEAST ON FOREIGN
POLICY.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE
CELEBRATING PEOPLE LIKE ORBAN
AND TUCKER CARLSON, WHO
CELEBRATE VLADIMIR PUTIN, AT
LEAST UP UNTIL THE INVASION,
RUNS COUNTER TO EVERYTHING I WAS
BROUGHT UP AS AS NOT ONLY AN
AMERICAN BUT ALSO A REPUBLICAN.
GOING TO HUNGARY TO CELEBRATE
ORBAN.
ALMOST IN THE TWILIGHT ZONE.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
WE SHOULD BE CELEBRATING LEADERS
WHO EMBRACE DIRECT VALUES AND
PRINCIPLES, FREE PRESS,
INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY, FREE
ELECTIONS.
NOT THESE FOLKS THAT ARE